[Music]
[Music]
chicken you can eat it for breakfast
lunch dinner and dessert yes I said
dessert venom is Mohammed och Bora
Szechuan Da Capo no Michelle domos Megan
is Kanak malevich's Mahmood is the
manager master chef and
second-generation owner of this charming
pudding shop one of the puddings they
specialize in is Tuvok gosu also known
as chicken breast pudding boo Choji
skier Daniel and mahogany me
togusa ot named Amber Lee Yahweh shave
ice tea elderly Shotaro a baklava Larry
- mom endure a talky solarek mr. bokun
pune ayatul terrace tokyo by sebastian
gia is a Batista's intricate it is step
one boil chicken just enough to take
apart the white meat and then move on to
step two makes water buffalo milk with
some cow's milk like you do and get that
boiling once that boils you can move on
to step 3 add in some broken rice and
once that starch is mixed with that
water buffalo milk you've got yourself
an emulsifier and that my friends is how
you make telugu sudha Aldens umbrella
vomited
no Pennsylvania Josiah tawa desiderio
solution there among you shall be
missing Canaria nutritious check amazing
flavor check check and the people of
Turkey really love it
yes initially available here after the
anaxander hear me - can I use Tony for
language sure usually tenemos una mr.
wizard chakras are in the South deserves
their models they then parka Jim is a
severity appears save Eric a lazy
optimism on foodon a mechanically yah
Laguna Salada
they were met religious we got to an
abortion say sue :
CC extra in suit Antica
[Music]
in the middle of the French Pyrenees
there's a cake that's been spinning and
spinning and spinning for over two
centuries
Joseph Pierre has formed a society to
keep the recipe going the map in Azusa
Foster is feeling pretty down there I
completely you got to an abortion ah and
he's in charge of a cake with quite a
curious past really spot on abortion
Lupo Conan Cooney soos only sold at the
Napoleon and E Honda son Janko homicide
on a hooker to the who she the cake is a
reminder that losing isn't always bad as
Napoleon soldiers retreated from Russia
they picked up the recipe from several
Eastern European countries and brought
it all the way to the Pyrenees for many
people including Joseph in his
Brotherhood have kept the bacon going
Lakhan fili ET que la bien - Vinton
Lucia conceit only shock encephalopathic
unsafely metal a pata so what's in it
Sanders guajillo de Barra da Tijuca
guajillo the Farina deleted Ahn
jung-hwan the Holika pero su Cthulhu
party common carp s cursing - AHA so
feel more open on certain loco person
propeller pata original new commands own
opposite a kusuda pata de casa su casa
silva a new personal apart abandon
Capitan Kira so departed Allah Mohammed
Samuel fatigue apart only legato allah
masha
you are we know nonporous casa
[Music]
nozomi no sane contender Gatto paha say
to tradition / du haut de Peterson's on
path Kaluga to Alamosa
yovanna legato incontrollable totally
foetida familia sandy answer dollars one
fabric on saga to pass Colonel
impression the transmat Raquel cosa you
know 16 Avila a to lotion and Sica to
lee jung-hyun only eating
[Music]
haven't you ever had those times in your
life where you just feel all consumed
with tasting something again that you
haven't had in years and years that's
really what I'm doing here is bringing
back those incredible desserts those
incredible experiences that have gone
extinct
I put myself through this process of
resurrecting deserts because I truly
feel that a good desert can change the
course of your day I'm Valerie Gordon
owner of Valerie confections and I'm
also a desert anthropologist the way
this project of resurrecting historic
deserts began was in 2009 the food
editor from the Los Angeles Times
magazine asked me to create a Blum's
coffee crunch cake for an article that
she was doing and it was this amazing
full circle moment because I grew up
with that cake I know that cake and I
missed that cake terribly plums was an
incredible bakery and cafe in California
there were eight locations the last one
closed in the 80s when the article came
out and we literally received 125 phone
calls from people going oh my god I want
this cake the desserts that I
resurrected to date are of course the
coffee crunch cake from Blum's I've
brought back the banana shortcake from
Jason's the Brown Derby grapefruit cake
is another cake that I've resurrected
and now is soon to be the coffee Estes
Sunday as well the Anthropology of the
desert resurrection is really one of the
most interesting parts of all of this I
start the research process at the
Central Library there is a room and this
is a very well guarded room called the
menu vault there are menus that date
back for 150 years
I find that looking at the actual menus
is so much more gratifying than just
pulling something up online because
you're really getting to the heart and
soul of the place
you're almost transported into that
place at that time by holding something
that these people held you really are
now I email a bunch of people or I call
a bunch of people who were natives to
Los Angeles or whatever city the bakery
was in to find out hey do you remember
this do you remember that we always used
to call this the adult Sunday because
this is the one my mom would eat can
they describe the texture of a whipped
cream can they tell me whether there was
vanilla in it or not I'm pretty sure
they did one basic yeah recipe for
whipped cream and then flavored
accordingly and right it was little kid
whipped cream one cherry yes this is
amazing like you've been indispensable
I'm not particularly interested in retro
it is about reliving those sense
memories it's sort of like when you hear
a song that was your favorite song from
1982 you're really thrown back into that
moment it's become this very emotional
very fulfilling part of my job to bring
these cakes back for people
[Music]
these little custard tarts these eggy
sugary treats are everywhere in Portugal
here here and here
some say the prestige the meringue is
the original post age Donata or a
custard tart in this little factory
through this kitchen there's a recipe
that has been kept top secret for almost
200 years like this one guys you can get
in here I'm sorry ok I'm Miguel perineal
I am part of the management's of the
stage blind this special recipe you will
only find here at this shop we sell an
average of about 20,000 tarts day in the
summer maybe around 40,000 cakes a lot
of cakes stage doubling as they call
them here are simple tarts really egg
yolk milk some flour sugar but it's how
they make them in complete secrecy that
makes these tarts a national treasure we
have six people knowing the recipe in
the family my father my cousin and
myself Miguel Farina the three chefs
Vitor Dominguez le0
Romero and Carol Lewis Martine the
recipe is so secret all the Baker's
signed non-disclosure agreements to keep
the timeless tarts a true mystery which
taste of life is one of the earliest
recipes at least here in Lisbon we know
that the recipe was invented in the
monastery of Geronimo's in the early
19th century this one once they have the
recipe the chef's now sworn to secrecy
are given keys to this door they work
inside the factory in a separate room
that we call the obscene a loose gravel
in Portuguese like the secret shop or
secret room they have to work in a
separate room
the process can only be seen by them so
today we haven't found anyone that
explained the recipe as it is if it
happens well we probably would have to
lock him up in the basement and throw
away the key
no just kidding okay secret keeper
what's the best way to eat one of these
custard tarts usually I like it simple
but that's just me most people like with
a little bit of cinnamon on top this is
the hard part of the job it's a super
hard I don't know how you do it